es un evento anual pero este año hay una
nube oscura sobre la conferencia de los
obispos franceses unos 120 prelados van
a dedicar la mitad de sus siete días de
reunión para encontrar maneras de luchar
contra la pederastia en la iglesia
católica esto llega un mes después de la
publicación de un informe que revelaba
abusos contra niños sistemáticos dentro
de la institución desde las asociaciones
de víctimas confían en que los obispos
sigan las 45 recomendaciones del texto
juntas son víctima para una víctima que
no puede ir a los tribunales porque el
incidente ocurrió hace mucho tiempo es
importante tener en cuenta dos cosas
primero reconocimiento el reconocimiento
de su estatus como víctima y segundo
abarcar todo el camino en un proceso de
reparación para su la investigación
estimó que en las últimas siete décadas
aproximadamente
216 mil niños fueron víctimas de abuso
por integrantes de la iglesia francesa
cifra que aumenta a 330 mil niños
contando los abusos de personal externo
relacionado con el clero algunas de las
víctimas han sido invitadas a esta
conferencia en el suroeste del
territorio galo
pocas van a acudir para el 5 de octubre
ningún obispo reconocía la
responsabilidad institucional de la
iglesia
y se esfuerzan por expresar su vergüenza
su dolor ellos están sufriendo y todo lo
que uno se pueda imaginar pero no hay
reconocimiento
se cree que encontrar un mecanismo para
ofrecer una reparación de las víctimas
es una de las prioridades de la
conferencia la comisión que completó las
pesquisas afirma que la compensación
debe ser financiada con los activos de
los agresores